hikaru nakamura's five most amazing
queen sacrifices
this deserved a blazer that's how
good the examples are how stunning they
are how amazing they are
see if you can spot knackers moves and
make sure you like and subscribe to this
channel
this first example is maybe his most
famous example
he's got the black pieces against strong
grand master chrysenko
and after the move d takes c4 kazrenko
played
knight to c6 now this has the idea
that after rook takes c6 white plays
bishop takes f6 and this is where
we start the queen is attacked and
white is trying to take the bishop on e7
what stunning idea did hikaru find here
and how did he follow up see if you can
analyze as deeply
as the naka monster did well he now
played
boom queen takes f2 oh la la la
look at that for a stunning move and
after king takes f2
the bishop moves into c5 with check
and the king hunt now starts white
moved his king up to f3 other options
are no better for example if he tries
blocking it
the bishop can simply take that rook and
if the king comes to this square
we can keep taking things with check and
now we're going to win the white queen
and this leads to a winning position had
the king come back to
f1 look at the power of those assassins
cheekily pointing at the white king and
with the move
c3 rookie 2 is the only way to
stop that check in a decent way but now
a brilliant move
c2 what a stunning idea there
so we go back to the game the king came
walking to its death
and hikari said okay time to kill
rook to f6 check king g4 another piece
comes
flying into the action knight to e5
check and this position is very bad all
of black's
remaining pieces are trapping that king
out in the open like no man's land the
king
is about to be taken down the king steps
to g5
and now rook g6 king h5 and here
a very nice move f6 this
threatens rook h6 which is checkmate
because we're covering the g5 square
and that white king is clearly in too
much danger
white tried rook takes e5 but now
another black rook came in the check
and after king h4 the next move forced
resignation bishop to c8
i love these quiet moves that hikaru
played here in the middle of the storm
did anyone
see all the way up to this position
that's kind of how far you need to see
if you want to be hikaru's strength and
with this move
rook h6 and other ideas are really
not going to be stopped here so white
reside this next one was taken from
the speed chest challenge on chess.com
and we have the very talented brilliant
player aronian with the white pieces
against hikaru and it's only a five
minute game making the next
couple of moves even that more stunning
now bishop e7 was aronian's idea to keep
attacking the black king and it does
look like the black king is
under some damage danger here but look
how hikaru
turns the position around queen takes e7
oh yeah aronian you're not attacking me
i'm gonna have some fun against you
yeah boy and now after knight takes e7
king takes e7 well black has given up
the queen
but as we're going to shortly see is the
white king which is in a lot of danger
with stuff like
rook g8 being the immediate threat the
game continued queen takes b7
and now just king d7 making sure the
white king
the white king is still weak and the
white queen can't get in the position
queen takes a6 pawn takes c3 opening the
bishop
and threatening bishop here check queen
b5 and now the king
is surprisingly safe on this square and
after
bishop to b6 the rook is going to come
in this way
queen to e2 stopping that but now my
favorite move this whole combination
rook a4 black finds a way to bring the
rook
over towards white's king and now the
pressure is just too much
queen to g2 and here knight g4
check that knight now defending and
after king h1
knight to e3 and white tri queen to c6
but rook h3 check is completely winning
as we're going to see the rooks coming
over here next move as well as other
things
so aronian resigned a great example of
turning defense into attack
something you guys should always try to
strive
for the initiative in this next example
we jump back to
1999 and little hikaru was still
very dangerous he's playing the wax man
here
and it's white to play how did he break
through defenses and remember you can
use that pause button
queen 2h5 check just
imagine sliding that move on to the
board how satisfying
it would be and this really has the main
aim of releasing the bishop on d3
that bishop becomes extremely strong for
example if the queen is captured
e5 check and now the only move is f5
but after knight takes f5 black really
has no defense
the bishop is now threatened to release
itself
rook g7 is another threat and if you try
to get rid of the knight just bishop
takes their fighters check
mate a lovely move black tried king g8
but after queen g6 it's clear to see
that white is completely winning great
play from hikaru yet again
now this is boris gelfand with the white
pieces against hikaru at black and
i have looked at this position before in
my series on the king's
indian defense if you're a premium
member on chess.com you can view that
series
now here hikaru's queen has been on pre
for a number of moves he doesn't
actually get the chance to sacrifice it
but
rather than now moving the queen he
plays bishop h3
and this is a beautiful move because if
the queen is captured here
this is czech mate and the fireworks
continue
white plays bishop to f1 covering that
square and can you now see
what hikaru played i love this move one
of my favorite ever
hikaru moves queen to d3
and yes i know i've looked at this
before but i had to include it again
it's just so
beautiful the idea is again if the queen
is taken
g2 is free and if the bishop is taken
we can come into f3 and then g2 with
checkmate
and in this position really white has no
defense
he tried knight takes e5 but now the
queen has again
left on pre with bishop takes f1 bishop
g2 to fret
and eventually hikaru just takes a
knight on c3
a lovely sort of series of moves there
just leaving that queen to be captured
but it can never be captured due to the
checkmate frets
beautiful those of you with a great
memory may
just recall how magnus carlsen defeated
sergey karjakin
with what's been called the best ever
checkmate
in the last game last move of the world
championships
but in actual fact the sequence and the
pattern
that magnus used was used first
by hikaru and in this game played
well before that world championships
it's now hikaru to move
he plays rook g1 check and after king to
a2
can you see the stunning move that
forced resignation immediately
and if you know that pattern and chess
is all about patterns so the more
patterns you learn
the better you get what move now can you
see remember the pattern in the in the
game can you see it
queen takes a free check and i love this
move because whatever happens
rook a1 is gonna be checkmate next move
exactly the same
sort of sequence we saw but hikaru got
it in first
well done hikaru so which of those five
examples was your
favorite queen sacrifice do leave your
comments below
please make sure you like and subscribe
to this video there's many other videos
in this series where you can look at
stunning moves stunning ideas to
hopefully
improve your play i'll be back with more
videos soon
goodbye and cheers for now